حسام تكسر صيامك بس سمبوسه اه ايش المشكله
كيف تكسرون صيامكم خشيه الطبق الرئيسي
ببدا بالمكبوسه
بعدها ننتقل
الرئيسيه لازم يكون متوازن بيحتوي على
عناصر غذائيه عديده
مثل الرز الاسمر البرغل او الكينوا
العصير هو يفضل مي طبعا بس انا بخش على
عصير صراحه طبعا هذا الشيء شائع جدا
برمضان ولكنه خطا كتير كبير وهذه
المشروبات عاليه جدا بالسكر وبترفع نسبه
السكر بالدم بشكل هائل وبتزيد كثير سعرات
الحراريه فمتده لزياده الوزن
هاي الي على ماده فاضيه مشكله كثير كبيره
يفضل دائما ما نبتدي بالمعالي لانها عاليه
جدا بالدهون ممكن تؤدي لمشاكل عديده
بالهضم مثل الامساك الكثير اشخاص
اول شيء
واضح انه في عط ولكن افضل طريقه انه نقسم
كميات المي بين الافطار وبين الصحون عشان
ما يصير معنا تلبك معوي ما تنسوا على وجبه
السحور ابتعدوا عن الماكولات العاليه جدا
بالاملاح مثل الاجبان المالحه لانها بتزيد
نسبه العطش خلال يوم الصيام بتمنى لكم
دائما دوام الصحه والعافيه